hello and welcome to this video playing
chess commandos I really have to get
some points then yeah two for 25 that's
that's not good but not having a good
day today don't feel so focused as a big
problem yes so maybe I get an automatic
win in the Petrosian yeah sometimes you
get that if they don't don't know it
well but white black is playing the
absolute main line him so it looks like
he has some some idea so a 3 B 3 those
moves are possible at age 7 it's not yet
threatening anything after ok now I have
to give myself a square this if he goes
g5f warm that is actually pretty bad
that typical attack doesn't work in the
Petrosian all that well let's see what
is what is planning a typical idea for
white here is an early B form even as a
pawn sacrifice we'll see if I get some
get to play this okay he just keeps that
keeps attention down maybe Knight age 5
to F force is one of his ideas I'm going
to retreat this voluntarily going to c8
that's a mystic bit of a mystery move
what is that doing so you want to play
the C pawn or I don't I don't quite know
uh-huh okay I can take with the night
here why not
one one constant issue in this in this
opening line for black is the night on a
six at night is not doing anything he
has to really go through some length to
make it someone to somewhat good piece
so night c5 now is some what he probably
wants to play yeah it's not a big deal
if he does but yeah I wonder still
wonder how I should play this now
even g4 comes into consideration to be
honest GeForce an interesting move let's
do it
no I'm not saying that I'm a pre moving
who should take before just because it
is the move that I would play with it's
not really what I expect him to do it's
not an easy decision though because
Bishop d7 is also kind of sad
you know a black has no would move now
here really what what to do them yeah so
now he's a ticking f3 some going to move
this Bishop and I'm threatening now
Queen d2 attacking h6 and threatening
before at the same time if I manage
before and it's really really bad for
him and the knight never moves it's a
really should not c5 I can take take g6
you know not easy at all for black you
know the drastic decision but maybe
something that's that was necessary
okay um not c5 I'm going to take I guess
yeah I don't need to take I can also
play 93 intending interesting many many
interesting ideas
yeah well it's a typical exchange sack
it doesn't work here but yeah I don't
want to take it in merely yeah now I can
take it down and I get to get the night
to age five
yeah he wanted to take with the e pawn
to make the bishop gg7 more open right
now them my rook is only one and okay
that is just not working
I have rookies seven and also it's very
close to an invasion with the Queen
so Bishop f5 is probably the next move
if I can trade these bishops and Queen
g6 I just have a winning attack here
okay so first check all not don't know
before it's also a good move
yeah if I go here and he take some place
Queen jf7 that it's not entirely clear
let's just do this ask him for a move
now if I go before it's not super clear
okay
spin the Queen I mean it's not super
clear in terms of how exactly I'm
winning not how the position is I can't
worked out reasonably well this this
plan is just not working really I mean I
already have my doubts about a 5 on a
stem but this has been played by some
strong players but I think it gets
Quincy 8 was a bit mysterious to me but
I think this is not a good idea you have
the engine agrees that would have been
maybe maybe somewhat playable if the
pawn pawns wouldn't be like that like if
it is on h7 and this is just not
you cannot stand such a position this is
weak this Knight is bad this Bishop is
bad and so on it's it's a bit too much
and the engine is also checking with us
here ok and take take Bishop d3 is a
good move b6 and I think after g4 it's
basically game over yeah
g4 is the best I had a very similar idea
in a tournament came in a classical time
control game about a year ago this is
also probably why a spot a g4 quite
quickly yeah what to do now and this is
this is a disaster the bishop on e4 it's
just like fantastically strong and he
has to do this maybe I mean what kind of
position is that I get to get descent
and the knight is also basically
stalemated on the edge of the water
yeah Bishop d7 and now this is just
terrible that was kind of clear that
rook a to e1 wasn't the best move in a
way that there was something more
energetic okay the engine gave h4
initially and now this is probably
strong I mean come on take screen edge -
[Music]
yeah I do you have all the time and if
every single piece of yours is better
than the opponent's you have time yeah
this exchange SEC doesn't work
I think so yeah maybe before but this is
a good move when you have little time
making a small improvement know he he
gave me gave me the house with this but
it's um you cannot cannot really hold
this I can go here and be for one yeah
it's just this too much in them in this
opening I think like I really should go
age five I think this is the better
choice like f3 Bishop h6 and so on it
continues from them I think that here
black has fear chances I still much
prefer white but that is some also
matter of taste probably thanks a lot
for watching